welcome to Horry sorry the China where
we discussed the latest tech news and
delve into newest tech products so today
we're taking a look at which GPU you
should buy for editing and gaming after
the mining room but before we delve into
that make sure to hit that subscribe
button if you guys would like to stay
updated with the latest tech news
related to gaming and PCs first of all
in this video I'm not going to be
talking about invidious new 1100 series
anbc new Nabi series and if you guys are
interested in the details of those new
GPUs then make sure to check out my
dedicated videos on them this video is
for people who are set on buying a GPU
right now but are having trouble
deciding which GPU is best for them and
which will best suit their needs also
before buying any of these GPUs I really
recommend that you guys wait a couple of
days and look for any deals because
these GPS are still dropping in price
and there are many unexpected deals that
pop up all the time for these GPUs so
really make sure to keep an eye out for
those deals before you buy one of these
so obviously when buying a GPU there are
three things to consider how much does
the GPU cost what performance will I
give you and how long will it last so
starting off the GTX 1050 1050 Ti the RX
560 and the rx 570 I wouldn't recommend
that you guys buy any of those cards
because all those cards are going to be
outdated very soon and they're the
entry-level card for both graphics card
series and so it doesn't really make
sense to buy an entry-level almost out
dated card right now so really you
should only buy those cards if you are
on a very strict budget but otherwise
you should wait and save some more money
or just spend some extra cash right now
and go for a 10 60 or rx 580 because
that really will be worth the extra
money so with that out of the way if you
guys are looking for a perfect value
card that can handle all of 1080p games
at 60 frames per second at Ultra
settings then the best cards for you are
the GTX 1060 and the rx 580 both these
cards have two variants within them
which have differing VM sizes however
all four of these options are viable and
reason
with the three gigabyte 1060 card and
the four gigabyte 580 card you will be
able to get solid 60 frames per second
1080p Ultra gaming for the next two to
three years however after that you will
probably have to dial it down to high on
some games if you want to maintain that
60 frames per second and ask for the 6
gigabyte 1060 and the a gigabyte 580
those cards will be able to handle 1080p
at 60 frames per second with ultra
settings for the next three to four
years but after that you will have to
dial it down just like the other cards
too high
however despite that small drawback the
1060 and 580 are still really good 1080p
graphics cards and are really good if
you want a graphics card for the next
three years or even if you want to keep
it longer for five years as long as
you're okay with dying down to graphics
a little bit but ask for value for the
money these two cards are probably the
best you're gonna get next up if you
want a graphics card that I can handle
1080p gaming with no problem at 60
frames per second at Ultra for the next
5 years or a graphics card that can
handle 1440p or 1080p ultra wide gaming
for the next three years before you have
to dial it down and the best graphics
card for you is the gtx 1070 right now
this graphics card can easily handle
1080p games and will be able to handle
1080p games all the way for at least 5
years in the future so if you want a
1440p slash 1080p ultra wide gaming
graphics card or a future-proof 1080p
graphics card then the gtx 1070 is the
best GPU for you if you want a graphics
card for triple monitor of 1080p gaming
1440p ultra gaming or a good 4k gaming
graphics card then the GTX 1080 is your
best bet
finally if you want a graphics card that
is really pretty much overkill right now
and it'll be very strong for the next 5
years or even more then the gtx 980ti
may be worth considering but for most of
you guys this is really overkill and
very unnecessary but if you want to get
the best performance available then this
is the card for you ask for us why just
just don't do it and ask for Vega
well invidious offerings for that range
of graphics cards it's just so much
better so
just don't get Vega next up which GPU
should you get for editing first of all
before we go any further I want to make
it really clear but the CPU is the main
component of video editing and the GPU
won't really make much of a difference
so I would never recommend that you guys
sacrifice a CPU level in order to be
able to afford a better GPU while GPUs
do assist in editing CPUs really do most
of the work so I really recommend that
you guys save most of your budget for
the CPU here the GTX 1050 and the 1050
Ti are actually pretty good options
because the CPU does supposed to work
and as a result these cards are actually
very viable options for video editing so
what should you look out for when buying
a GPU for video editing first of all
don't make your GPU purchase based on
the vram that a GPU has because while
virion is really good for things such as
3d modeling theorem doesn't really
affect a video editing very much so
don't make your decision based off of
that really the best way to gauge the
video editing power of a graphics card
is by looking at its scores which is
measured in CUDA cores for video what
about AMD you ask well unfortunately
NVIDIA GPUs are just so much more
optimized for video editing software's
like Premiere Pro and After Effects so
there really is no reason to buy an AMD
GPU for video editing so when buying a
GPU for video editing
stick to Nvidia don't make your decision
based on vram and make sure look at the
cuda cores because that is what will
translate into real world performance as
for video editing
so which graphics card should you get
for video editing well in my opinion
there are four tiers - all video editors
fall into and that is what will
determine which graphics card is best
for you
again I really recommend that you guys
buy the best CPU that you can and at
least eight gigabytes of ddr4 Ram
preferably 16 gigabytes before you make
any decisions of your GPU with that
being said if you're just a casual video
editor or even if you're serious but you
don't add it too often then I really
recommend the gtx 1050 or 1050 Ti
because that is really all you need if
you're a bit for a serious and you would
like
keep her GPU for a longer time then I
recommend that you guys get the GTX 1060
because it is much better for the
long-term and it does have a decent
performance upgrade over the GTX 1050
and 1050 T I asked for video editing
finally if you're a very serious about
your editing like for example you make
money off what you do then you may want
to consider the gtx 1070 because that
will last a very long time and it will
make your life during that period
slightly better but again really the gtx
1060 is really all you need
finally if you want to go over the top
then you may want to consider the gtx
1080 or 1080i but when you look at it
from a performance standpoint on video
editing the 1060 1070 1080 and 1080 TI
all have performance that is very
similar and it's really quite negotiable
and I don't think that it's worth the
extra money that you would need to spend
so as a result for most people I
recommend that they just get a GTX 1060
because now it lasts a solid five years
or even more and deliver really good
performance and the performance
difference between that and that cards
above that isn't very small and it
really wouldn't make that much of a
difference if you are super serious and
really care about longevity and you may
want to go for the gtx 1070 but really i
do think that is a bit overkill
i would really just recommend sticking
to the gtx 1060 so that's who I think
should buy each level of graphics card
as for editing and gaming so do you guys
agree with my judgment or do you think
that the gtx 1080i is a must if you want
to get into gaming or that a GPU is not
even necessary for video editing make
sure to comment down below what you guys
think because I do read all my comments
and I'm curious as to what you guys
think so make sure to post your thoughts
also if you guys like this view then
make sure drop a like and hit that
subscribe button if you guys would like
to see more videos just like this one
well until next time
[Music]